and like to me that was like so [ __ ]
relatable because I'm like oh my god
I've done that so many even more when he
goes I'm just gonna chop his head off
and put on my fridge I'll do that and
you're like relatable
[Music]
all right we're gonna do it y'all we're
gonna talk about Mr Jeffrey Dahmer Oh I
thought you could say absolutely I know
I thought so too documentary this show
is [ __ ] up dude where's the list what
episode are you on I couldn't get I
watched me and my wife try to watch the
first episode like two times couldn't
get through it finally got through it on
the third time then we watched
the second episode and I'd turn it off
it's because you keep [ __ ] eating
pulled pork in the middle
yeah you shouldn't be eating right you
can't eat too similar yeah oh roast beef
no roast beef don't have a Cuban
sandwich the SEC the second episode is
when they introduce the uh the young
Filipino boy who's 14 and it's like a
very famous Jeffrey Dahmer story and
then you watch it because it's creepy
because it's like uh the guy who plays
Jeffrey Dahmer does such a good job of
making you feel like you're in the
[ __ ] room with him you know while
he's trying to like oh interesting like
about to murder you and you know as an
audience member what's gonna happen to
the [ __ ] guy and then I'm too [ __ ]
to watch it I had to turn it off did you
watch it right no I haven't seen it I've
seen other Jeffrey Dahmer like past
films and documentaries though yeah the
documentary yeah yeah I've got some you
know we've got a little news article on
it but while we're still on the TV show
about it I will say that isn't this
low-key one of the reasons or the the
incentives of such Manifesto like serial
killers that want to become the stuff of
Legends oh yeah like this dude's
literally got and Netflix even like
promotes it's one of the like top 10
shows of all time in the first Xyz weeks
that it's been out or whatever they made
so many movies dude he's gonna live
forever they've already got like 196
million hours of streaming or some [ __ ]
like he's immortalized what's with our
culture and our Obsession and the story
is called Dahmer it's like just Dahmer
yeah glorified and it's a drama it's not
even documentary that talks about like
what happened it's like it's it's
dramaticized and you know what's weird
in this uh
it's it's [ __ ] weirdly relatable
so again everybody understands what
happens
hey not to this not to this not to this
time related
paint I gotta say real quick as a white
man you can't do that to me because
people mostly think I'm a serial killer
most like more likely than not your
outfit says no your outfit says rap
artist trying to make it still thank you
still I prefer Clay Art but for example
in these
second episode with the Filipino boy no
no no
maybe I'm talking about the third
episode just talk about it okay point is
there's there's other episodes which
episode is it I think it's the third
episode I think it's third episode well
where uh he's got the hitchhiker got it
I'm not familiar with the hitchhiker no
but I'm sure they're wrong yeah they all
end up dead so yeah basically he knocks
out this hitchhiker uh after you know
he's trying to just smoke weed drink
some beer hang out and he's got this
like whole abandonment issue thing where
he's like why is everybody trying to
leave me why is everyone trying to leave
you don't leave me right and you guys
like I gotta go to this concert so I
[ __ ] hitchhiked with you you're being
weird but he's also discovering his
homosexuality so he like kind of like
awkwardly kisses this dude in a moment
where he thinks it might be appropriate
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
Ryan he gets like and and it's it's
human so that's why relatables it's
relatable because I'm also in the closet
right Jeffrey Dahmer's gay yeah yeah
yeah yeah so there's this moment though
this this is what I mean by like again
Hot Topic [ __ ] hot take [ __ ] weird
relatable yeah
he kills this guy accidentally in a
sense by by Passion it's not accidental
he knocks him with a [ __ ] like uh uh
[ __ ] 45 pound plate weight or
something like that and then afterwards
the guy's still kind of like what are
you doing he's like man [ __ ] you and
then he like kind of chokes him out and
then when he chokes down the guy stops
moving that's when he's like in his mind
I I feel you could tell it's like he's
like oh [ __ ] did I kill him so he starts
freaking out this is his first kill this
is like a a memory or something like
that and then he has this like again
you're you're you're in the room so you
get this really really strong feeling
that you're there and he he does this
very human freaking out like he just
killed his first guy but the Twisted
thing is you know this guy's killed like
17 other dudes or or in the finale yeah
he just didn't quit yeah he didn't quit
but this is like kind of his relatable
first time doing it
and he freaks out and he tries to figure
out how to do stuff and he like
frantically tries to hide the body and
then he gets the different ideas and he
like pulls his body out and he's trying
to figure out what to do and it makes it
awkwardly relatable like they're
humanizing this guy yeah well it's kind
of like Joker too right with Joaquin
Phoenix Joker's a fictional guy though I
know but you really like you relate to a
psych like a psycho and you're like okay
yeah cause you're like oh I could have
if I was in a situation where I
accidentally killed somebody you could
relate to the feeling of like what the
[ __ ] am I going to do
it plays double Advocate yeah for
exactly for the psychology of people are
just born like that yeah right and he
humanizes him because it then it starts
to show like his family environment the
way he grew up the way that his
schoolmates treated him though he was
bullied and you start humanizing this
Psychopathic killer who [ __ ]
chopped up and ate some of this but they
make it so relatable because you're
watching this thing and then like he
just killed this guy right and then he
took like going to his kitchen cabinets
like we all do it's like do I want soup
or do I want chili
and like to me that was like so [ __ ]
relatable because I'm like oh my god
I've done that so many even more when he
goes I'm just gonna chop his head off
and put in my fridge I'll do that and
you're like relatable relatable it's
like oh I should probably it's like oh
okay Nikki ordered too much takeout I
should probably put this in the fridge
yeah we should probably save it for
later in the week yeah we've all been
there see what you guys trying to do but
watch episode three yeah dude I think
I'm done watching I'm gonna watch it
it's it's
I usually like serial killer stuff as
far as like a documentary standpoint
that's what I'm saying I feel like
documentary you're like uh consuming the
information as uh things that happened
yeah but then when there's like a
perspective through the writing that
like takes a a fictional approach to
what may have happened that caused this
person to do it it's psychologically
twists your understanding is it is it
are you guys like on the fence of it of
like is it celebrating it is it
glorifying it is it maybe even promoting
this type of [ __ ] but also at the same
time it is it just really good art
because it's really good writing that
makes it relatable I think it's all the
above I think when something's difficult
to understand people are going to be
attracted to trying to understand it
I always honestly when I heard of the
story of Dahmer I thought that he was a
from scratch guy I didn't know he used
chili kits
the seasoning packets were you
disappointed yeah I was like wow he's
getting some Carol Shelby chili kid out
might as well have some ragus
I thought the guy was like dicing
himself I didn't know I didn't know yeah
yeah you know what's funny is that he
was on the go a lot I wonder I wonder if
there's a difference in in the culture
today because like the way that this is
being dissected where people are like oh
it's glorifying it oh it's whatever like
there's been a shitload of Dahmer
content through the 90s oh yeah and
every time I remember just like people
joked about it instantly yeah like even
in school in a seven damn it this like
Mega Christian School we were joking
about it with teachers it was like a
butt of joke it was a punchline just say
things were Dahmer like you bite another
kid oh easy there Dahmer like it was a
joke and and nobody took it like oh we
shouldn't put him on the news and
glorify it like I don't maybe I don't
just remember that but like instantly
there were tons of even shitty movies
about Dahmer dude
party of like four was like a funny bit
when we were kids in the playground like
like you know because when you go to a
restaurant back then it's like oh your
party of like three or whatever so it's
like oh yeah my name is Dahmer like
parties in the seven and it's like
you know you're gonna eat seven people
or whatever like that was the bit yeah
dude that was a thing I wonder if it's
like that's kind of that's more
sensitive today
I'm I'm speaking not from a place where
I'm like yo you're glorifying you're
gonna you're gonna [ __ ] inspire all
these murders like either way there's
gonna be a [ __ ] ton of serial killers in
America specifically and only for some
reason right and white dudes don't
forget I have a question do you okay so
in the show they the debated on
destroying the brain or preserving for
science preserving for science so what
do you guys think do you think that
somebody with the mentality of a serial
killer do you think we should study it
or do you think we should just answer
like a person or a politician both okay
so as a politician I would say why would
you want to preserve a Serial Killer's
brain
what are you running for
city council I vote for it regardless
of
this
um as a person I say yes study the [ __ ]
out of it like let's understand how this
[ __ ] happens and why so do you think
it's more on the brain or on the human
development nurturing I think it's I
think it's a combo dude yeah I think so
you think there's a part of his brain
that was destined to be [ __ ] up in
someone apparently in the show I don't
know how true this is I don't know if
they put it in as like a filler for the
script or something they were talking
about how he had a surgery when he was
young and I think that the anesthesia
might have affected his brain well his
mom took a lot of those pills a lot of
medication when he was when she was
pregnant with him so there's that and
then there's there's a they showed An
Origin story of how like him and his dad
would just pick up roadkill and they
would like dissect it and then like open
it up and like take the guts out and
it's like it was more of like a science
thing like hey check it out and he's
it's a it's a hobby that they got into
unless they can find a common
denominator with every person that was
dommer-ish and there's something that
they all had in their brain I think
that's kind of cool but if but you'd
have to study them yeah but that's
that's the only reason I would be like
yeah another thing I'm hearing about
this is like you know like um he's gay
right so like people are saying that you
know a lot of people in the gay
community I'm hearing are saying like
hey like this is making it look like
like
cause and effect the gay people cause
and effect like that's not fair yeah I
know that's a wild bro I get it I get it
for them because they're like dude we've
been [ __ ] with that's what happened in
the 90s yeah exactly so like dude how
come like you know in Silence of lambs
of course the guy's got to be gay and so
you know I get all that too so like it's
it's a little bit tougher but like this
is just his story that's just like who
but I feel like if you if you look at
all the serial killers that have been
very popular in American culture most of
them are like violent towards women
anyway it looks like dudes that are like
most of them are products just [ __ ]
deranged yeah like Ted Bundy Ted Bundy
right that's the typical stereo yeah
he's the guy he's he's like yeah I think
studying the quote-unquote apex of the
typical serial killer it might be a
great use of scientific tax dollars so
that there might be something that can
be relatable but I think like a one of
one or a very unique case is like
that's I'm sure science and research but
I feel like they do have a profile now I
just don't I don't think we know what it
is but uh they for sure have a profile
and like it's like scientifically
studying the brain after a deceased like
murderer the way that you're gonna find
out like their upbringing is the
correlating response to why these I
think you have to compare all of them
let's just start it like hey if you want
to eat people I think we should you know
we'll probably look at that one first
yeah we'll check you out we'll check
that one out because it seems like he
was like
I think for a lot of serial killers as
they get more kills in they tend to like
change their methods over time
like they're desensitized to it yeah
because it like they talked about it
with the Golden State killer right he
was the guy that went up and down the
California coast his KD ratio was crazy
yeah no it's it's nuts it's like I think
100 and something but they would talk
about how he started only breaking in
and then he started like only breaking
in and then raping women and then they
knew exactly when his first kill was and
then after his first kill then he
started being more experimental with how
he killed the women and then it became
him killing the men and the women so
like it gradually continued to change
and evolve which in a weird way in their
mind they probably think of it as like
their body of work which is a really
[ __ ] up way to think about it but that
becomes her trade like an attachment to
that identity the Japanese cannibal you
know I'm talking about the infamous one
who who's still yeah who's still free
who's written like 20 [ __ ] books
about it and like makes a living off of
his cannibalism and cereal makes [ __ ]
accountable cameos he uh for everybody
who doesn't know he like was studying
abroad in like Europe or some [ __ ] in
Paris or something [ __ ] kill some
chick and then they drop charges when he
had gone back and then because there was
dropped charges in the interim he
couldn't be [ __ ] tried uh in Japan
yeah on a technicality in a loophole
he's able to walk free but the thing
that he talks about one of the very
famous things he talks about is that one
of his big regrets is that after he
killed her and he ate her he's like man
I should have tried eating her while she
was alive instead of dead
and so he he he literally dreamed he's
like he's like when I dream it I have to
do it he's like before I die I have to
try so it's like a curiosity thing that
he's trying to say for him he literally
talks about a cannibalism as like the
next step in natural human desire if you
can desire a human whether it be like
sexually or whether it be like just
wanting to like control them or eat them
eat them is just the next phase it
shouldn't be weird that's his mentality
though didn't he say the reason he did
that was because he felt like that was
his way of being closer to them and them
being a part of him is to be able to eat
them he said too when he was a kid that
that's that was his inclination that he
saw like thighs and was like I just want
to eat them whoa and he doesn't want to
regret not eating them by the time he
dies because he wants to satisfy that
Curiosity that's the brain we need to
look at
can we not have him for a careful boys
chicken
I think we should check in with them
just for the safety and Bart should put
a shirt on during that yeah yeah I think
two shirts two shirts dude you first
have the juiciest thighs